first off happy belated birthday thank
you
it looked like you guys had a nice
little oppenheim family celebration for
the birthday too
yeah i was rolling mary no
no they weren't rolling at all okay well
because i saw that i was like oh
season four we're getting one it's
happening because this is usually around
the time you guys start filming your
birthday is usually at the beginning of
the season so i got my hope
yeah oh i hope so too i think that we'll
probably get it but we still don't know
until i guess a couple weeks after uh
season three airs
so everyone needs to binge i don't like
being around people like that like this
egotistic
male yes i don't like it it turns me off
why don't you be your own
broker would you ever
consider living
you christine and maya have a pretty
deep conversation about leaving
the o group where do you stand now
is that still a thing you think about no
and it's something that i never really
thought about it was more like maya
so here's the thing me and my husband we
bought a house here in miami last year
and i'm trying to
just you know stay put in miami that's
that's the goal yeah
you talked to jason about what if we
opened an oppenheim group
in miami so could selling south beach
be something 100 so the producer did had
an idea to do a spin-off in miami and i
think miami has always the sexiness
and the luxury but yeah opening a
brokerage it's not an easy thing to do
and i don't know if they can provide
drama as much as our show does
so god i ate dinner last night and i
didn't even think to invite you
i'm a horrible friend
[Laughter]
i'm bringing it drama tea looks
bullsh attitude theft everything i was
there for it and the other girls were
like
i'm here to be a professional i'm like
[ __ ] that's all the show's about
what would you like to show on the show
in a season four
few words it's very simple real estate
if the girls want less drama then stop
stop being so dramatic you know
like there's going to be fights you know
i think all of us want to get back on
track just being like
good friends having fun together and um
not so much talking you kind of see the
separation it was like
christelle mary and amanza and i was
more over on the davina
christine maya side yeah um in real life
i'm i've shifted i am on that other side
if we get a season four there's a lot of
time between when you last
filmed and when you could film next
i think it's going to be really
interesting because if we do shoot it's
not going to be until next year
it's giving everyone a chance to cool
off and like heal the wounds that have
been
season three and also the dynamics gonna
be changing you know davina is a broker
brett has left the brokerage started his
own firm yeah i mean we didn't see this
one coming
we'll see what happened well it'll be
interesting are we competing with right
now
right is it going to be like a brokerage
a brother brokerage office would you
ever go
work for brett no i think you know
oppenheim group is my home like with
jason
and and the girls so um i'm gonna i'm
gonna stay there
i might move brokerages or open my own
and who knows what the other girls are
gonna do lots and lots of things will
happen so it might be kind of juicy and
fresh new information will be available
you see how we move there's
been weddings deaths here like there's
like people i wouldn't be surprised who
knows
i could have have adopted eight kids by
then who knows what could happen
but by the time comes up the way
christine's going about it like will she
be back or does she think you know
because clearly she carries the show i
heard
like in i don't know would you want to
show more of your home life more of
time with christian of course i want to
see more of our personal life in our
home
and you know we're talking about
starting a family sometime soon and all
those great things
i want to be able to balance and show
for you all
you know for everyone a lot will have
happened as you
as you probably heard you know tarik and
heather got engaged so that's
huge news that's fantastic look at her
hand yes she said yes that's the future
that's foreign
i'm so excited and so happy did you
expect it at all when it actually
happened
so we were filming for a flipping 101 i
didn't think it was going to be a
proposal
so cameras were rolling but they were
not the selling sunset cameras no
they were hdtv's cameras so you can
appear on his
show but he can't appear on your show
i'm allowed to appear on one episode for
his show
okay and he doesn't have that carve out
for himself to go beyond one episode of
selling sunset
you know we might have a special um
special announcement to make for season
four if we get season four there's a
possibility he might be jumping on
okay because i was that would be my next
question it's a big deal to get
engaged and uh to not be able to
share any part of that on a show that's
about your life you know
he is a huge part of my life and yeah
there might have been a deal made
so okay well that also makes me feel
good about you know
season four me too i mean there's a lot
of
chess pieces waiting to be moved across
the board
so i think it's gonna be the most
interesting season
we ever will have if it happens